I'm gonna be honest with you usually
when we shoot a remote segment we start
early in the day when I have a lot of
energy today things got a little delayed
then I decided to go have a big lunch
I'm not kidding I had really big I had
like a giant turkey burger anyway I will
get my energy back in a second let's go
talk to the staffers parents hey Ashley
hey Conan yeah did you hear we're doing
here today can I move this of course you
guys watch the show they do okay every
night do you think what do you know
where they are right now yeah they're at
their store yeah what kind of store do
they have a kid's shoe store
hi dad yeah so someone wants to talk to
you hello is this Nick Nick hi this is
Conan O'Brien from the Conan show how
are you I'm fine how are you do you
watch this program that we make here I
usually watch it the next morning
because my wife tapes it because I go to
nighty night did you just say I go to
nighty night okay you sell kids shoes so
you're around little children all day
long exactly so you just said I went
nighty night and I just realized why you
said that because you work with children
well I'm gonna doubt
did you have lunch today I'm eating
right now
I had a big turkey burger and then I had
french fries and there's a salad or
fries option and I went with fries and
it was and I'm just I'm dragging ass
right now we got me a coffee
could someone seriously can someone get
me a skim latte please your daughter's
doing an amazing job I have my arm
around her right now I'm like a brother
right I'm a brother but you find me hot
right I'm like a brother do you think
it's hot is this creeping you out sir I
don't want to cause any problems Hey do
you mind if I talk to you for a second
nah I want to find it get some feedback
on the show uh probably my my grandpa
your grandpa my papa
you'd have called circle what's his name
Circle Circle he'll okay okay so it's
like I mean obvious it's ethical that's
what the [ __ ] does he wear suspenders
and build robots in the basement mister
no this is Conan O'Brien I'm fine how
are you
you can tell me anything you want
you're not gonna get in trouble press
here is gonna work with me until the day
I die
yeah yeah one more year so now hotels
gonna tell Chris later I want to bum
them out but is it hip surgery oh you
just had hip surgery and you've got to
go you gotta go get your therapy yeah
you know this is Conan O'Brien calling
you
mr. Hill this is a big deal
are you and giving you a chance to
change the future of television and you
you dear saying I got to run out the
door
[Music]
what do you this is Adam how's it going
sir how are you Adam good let's get my
chair I didn't know you had a chair Adam
so squeaky chair over there
is that you craving sorry all right will
you just stop what's going off the chair
I know it's been broken since I had it
okay
well I'm you know I'm trying to shoot a
remote here okay and it sounds like a
pirate ship three-hour time difference
yeah okay phones ringing a lot
interesting we have an answering machine
but it only picks up after six model
they don't make anymore maybe turned it
maybe it picked up but instead of a
greeting it's just a more ring it out I
don't get impatient after the prom with
your generation this is in the old days
when I was a kid used to let a phone
ring 120 times
picked it up
hi and Loretta hi Lee this is Conan
O'Brien from the Conan show I'm here
with Adam your phone I'm just letting
you know rings about a hundred and sixty
times before the answering machine picks
up which begs the question and I'm not
trying to be rude I don't know you but
what's the point of having an answering
machine if it waits until the person has
grown a full beard before it picks up so
if there's probably an adjustment on the
back you probably have it set to I'm
guessing 165 rings I think you can slide
the button over to four rings and I
think you'll have you probably missed
some great calls by the way six years
ago you won the lottery just worth six
hundred million dollars but well you
didn't get that message because the
people at the lottery they didn't think
you had a machine I'm sorry I'm yelling
but now to compensate for the turkey
burger I had a giant turkey burger at
lunch
I mean I'd shout down on this thing it
looked like a cow's head made of Turkey
and I got sleepy and now I've had a lot
of a latte and now I'm getting kind of a
little bit of a buzz so I'm usually not
this I'm gonna use the word obstreperous
I don't even think that's correct
anyway I'm gonna hang up now but you'll
never hear this because you've never
seen a message on your answering machine
that blinking red light means you have a
message okay that's not an electrical
fire all right I'm hanging up now we'll
try you on your cell which will probably
ring somewhere around 400 times before I
pick it up over now
I don't want are they gonna find that
funny or though I don't think I don't
know they've never met you before talk
to you so I don't know how they should
be on they may ask me why I Conan was
yelling at them now Kramer has that kind
of chair and you have this fancy chair
and that doesn't seem right
yeah hello is this Millie Millie this is
Conan O'Brien I'm here with your
grandson he's doing a great job
you watch me every night good huh I'm
looking for advice on how to improve the
show we're gonna do escape with some
funny thing well I do comedy on the show
have you seen my comedy yeah
well I was hoping the comedy was
entertainment and make a skit out of
something yes I will Isis from Millie
you're pretty good Millie you want to
come out here and help us out whatever
show was like like when Jerry Springer
was the big show she watched that when
like she's yes she likes teacher stays
current yeah
and now that I'm Jerry Springer she
watches me yeah alright Anna go in a
back room and shoot myself thank you
though
thank you she your help and clean up
this whole area it's big sty
do you like your chair
use that one
[Applause]